my name is Spencer Clays and I  specialize in deep cleaning and removing  layers of moss off of roofs  the area that you live in in the climate  definitely plays a huge factor in into  the amount of moss that goes on roofs  generally if it's green or black or  something living up there it needs to be  removed  I'll generally start any cleaning  process with the leaf blower and the  brush getting all that organic material  off before I start treating it  we really want to be careful when we're  brushing if you brush too hard you can  definitely damage the shingles but if  you're doing it the right way you're  doing it gently you can just get rid of  that Moss like by just gently kind of  flicking It Off